ich freue mich auch also irgendwie ich habe
schon Vertrauensproblem Moment wenn sie sich
er war irgendwie also kein Bock mehr ja das
ist ständig gibt schlechte Nachrichten von
schlecht gelaunten Leuten in schlechten sitzenden
Anzügen ja würde mir wünschen der Klaus Kleber
würde mal sagen guten Abend zum heute journal
heute war nichts nicht mal Wetter gute Nacht
bis ich immer irgendwas und früher war
es auch so einfach mit dem Vertrauen ja
früher wusste man der Ami gut der
russische Nutella gut nussflipöse
das war so einfach war heute ist Barack
Obama und Friedensnobelpreisträger und
du Vertrauensperson eine Vertrauensperson die
die halbe Welt bespielt tut und Guantanamo Bay
betreibt 2019 seine Amtsübernahme hat er gesagt
er wird das Ding innerhalb eines Jahres schließen
das Teil gibt es immer noch das einzige
was Obama geschlossen hat war das Büro
das mit der Auflösung von guantanamobile
und in dieser unreflektierten Welle der
Begeisterung hat man ihm dann 2009 auch
noch den Friedensnobelpreis verliehen
nachdem man ein paar Tage zuvor 30.000 Männer und
Frauen nach Afghanistan in den Krieg geschickt hat
dafür nehmen Friedensnobelpreise
für dein Oscar kriegen müssen
Barack Obama den Friedensnobelpreis zu verleihen
ist genauso als wenn sie den Attentätern vom
11 September 2001 nachträglichen
Preis für Städteplanung verleihen
ja so abwegig ist es gar nicht momentan hat
in Hamburg Städtebau Städteplanung studiert
der damals schon immer gedacht
ich mache später mal was mit heute
ich weiß nicht mehr wem ich vertrauen kann was
ich früher habe ich ihm gedacht der ADAC ist
in seriöser Laden inzwischen weiß ich das sind
selbst die Hells Angels transparente aufgestellt
die haben Abstimmungsergebnisse
und Wahlbeteiligung so radikal
gefällt da hat sogar bekommen
aber ich weiß inzwischen warum die
gelbe Engel heißen die haben sich
beim kaputtlachen über die Gutgläubigkeit
ihrer Mitglieder immer in die Hose gemacht
wem kannst du noch vertrauen
guck mal wem kannst du noch vertrauen guck
mal FC Bayern München haben wir immer gesagt
okay wir sind bei unsympathisch das sind
Arschgeigen aber die machen dann ehrlichen
Job inzwischen weiß ich höhnische Steuerbetrüger
Karl-Heinz Rummenigge wurde mit einer Hand voll
unverzollte Rolex am Flughafen erwischt und
einen Innenverteidiger sieht wegen Brandstiftung
im Knast wenn die so weitermachen haben die
Bank mehr vorbestraft also Nationalspieler
die Nummer mit dem Höhen ist es doch unglaublich
30 Millionen Euro steuerhinterzogen das kannst
doch kein nüchtern erklären und jetzt muss
ich ein Knast und so richtig so aus zwei
Gründen erstens Gericht und zweitens freue
ich mich auf die dummen Blicke der Bayern
wenn nächstes Jahr die knastmannschaft der
JVA Landsberg die Champions League gewinnt
bin ehrlich verstehe ich nicht gut die katholische
Kirche die macht alles richtig seit Jahrhunderten
ja das Management da oben ist
okay Problem ist Bodenpersonal
ein Kardinal Meißner der sich aus einer
Karriere mit den Worten verabschiedet
eine Familie von euch ersetzt mir drei muslimische
das ist dieser integrative Gedanke
fragt man sich ob der den
Weihrauch in der Pfeife raucht
ja ist es bei dem noch Demenz oder schon Tollwut
oder Bischof teewart von Gold Elster ein Typ
der Stiftung für bedürftige Menschen schließt
und sich parallel den Traum vom goldenen Bistum
erfüllt das ist ein Palast da hingesetzt ja wäre
jeder amerikanischer gangster rapper neidisch
geworden und wenn die den nicht gestoppt hätten
dann hätte der sich noch die Elbphilharmonie
als Parkhaus für seine Autos gekauft
den kann ich vertrauen
ich habe früher auch immer eine Werbung
geglaubt Katzen würden Whiskas kaufen
wochenlang habe ich im Supermarkt am
tierfutterregal da kam nie eine Katze rein
inzwischen weiß ich auch warum meine Katze mit dem
durchschnittlichen mindestlohn-job
kann sie überhaupt nicht leisten
in diesem Sinne guten Abend zum heutigen
Journal heute war nichts weiter gute Nacht
Qualität
also ZDF heißt ZDF und da ist Qualität und wenn
sie ZDF oder 3sat ist auch
also öffentlich-rechtlich
abonnieren